we've got meryl kelly on the mound he
has been meryl the mainstay
coming off back to back starts against
the chicago cubs the second one was
actually better than the first one
that's a real rarity merrill
just carved up the cubbies last time out
and the first pitch of the ball game is
hit
in the air behind shortstop backing out
as ahmed coming on peralta
david calls off ahmed and makes the
catch
muncie at second base for la tonight
waves at a curve ball
good start for merrell strikeout number
one turner at second base smith but
first with two outs
aj pollock red hot right now
merrill kelly strands two gets two
strikeouts so both tonight for the
dodgers that begin with mitch white even
though he's been exclusively a reliever
in the big leagues for the dodgers was
built up as a starter in triple-a
0-2 to kelly outside corner got him
looking strike three
that meter at third two gone and a one
two for mitch white calhoun
pulls the line drive to second and it's
caught by muncie to strand the man at
third and get this game to the second
scoreless
kelly right back in it stranded two in
the first now he's got two on no ounce
in the second
this is slicing high in the air short
left peralta is there
one down down the pitcher mitch white
cabrera creeping in
it's white strikes out bunsen foul
stupid bad
hate this path back to the top for
taylor
so good in these situations two
outrunners in scoring position
he rips a line drive into left center
field to open the scoring coming through
again with two gone
bellinger into scoring a base hit from
chris taylor and the dodgers lead one
nothing
first and third two down first ball
swinging that ball is lined into right a
base hit
beatty will score it's two nothing
dodgers
and chris taylor goes first to third on
the play
max muncie didn't wait around as he
drives in his 62nd run
corners again as justin turner comes up
runner takes off throw goes into center
field
so they coax the throw out of kelly and
it gets away from him to bring in
taylor three-nothing game as we go to
the bottom of the second drew ellis
swing and a miss strikeout to open the
second for white one away in the second
for david peralta
two two to peralta caught strike three
fastball at 95
over the inside corner two up two down
in this second and here's nick ahmed
swings at the first one bouncer up the
middle muncie position behind the back
throws him out and another efficient
inning for mitch white him
six hits through two innings all singles
and trails at three nothing
merrill's got five strikeouts he's
punched out aj twice
ahmed is there spins and throws nick
ahmed makes it look so easy
to meryl kelly 0-2 pitch swinging a miss
thanks for coming three up and three
down for merrill kelly
3-1 popped up right side of the infield
the first baseman beatty calling for it
he's got plenty of room to make the
catch
three up and three down for the second
straight inning and mitch white has
retired eight in a row
merrill obviously could use a real quick
one two three in it here keep that pitch
count down get his team back in that
dugout swinging the bass
and mckinney spanks that one out to
right cole calhoun runs it down
to the pitcher bats for the second time
and there it is that's six
for merrill kelly two outs of the fourth
taylor singled and scored
in the second he clubs another base hit
into left field
chris taylor my goodness watch the bat
on this replay
it's like a copy over and over again
this swing
three and a half back of the giants
ellis has got it and meryl kelly's
through four but trails at three nothing
josh van meter leading off this fourth
that's why it's been fantastic
next offering to van meter breaking ball
swing and a miss strike three got him
that is his fifth strikeout old calhoun
they hit her
get a hit and start a rally they're not
that far out of it but one swing
call a drive to deep right field back at
the wall
gone two-round homer home run for
calhoun it's three to two what were you
saying
just that one swing that's what we need
he blistered that ball
a walk followed up by a two-round homer
in a 3-2 ball game diebacks within one
that's where we are lincoln turner still
with that aggressive approach against
merrill kelly one pitch went out in the
field merrill is still throwing only 61
pitches in the ball game
there's a fly ball in the left hit it
pretty well peralta back though
out toward left center he makes the
catch and that's odd number two
live ball deep to right field calhoun
backing up on the warning track
hayes got it three outs on six pitches
for merrill kelly
three two dodgers the combat will either
on bottom of the fifth on him
fly ball left field here come in
there it's gone we are all tied at three
they've come back from three nothing
down
and nick has always been a guy that's
handled himself nicely against lefties
he takes clevenger
deep to left the seventh kelly has been
terrific once again
very efficient he's got five strikeouts
he's walked only one batter all night
long
taylor skies one to
well right helps one pitch one out
how about this from merrell kelly over
his last three starts two against the
cubs and tonight against the dodgers 42
of his 61 outs have been on three
pitches or fewer
and there's
[Applause]
88 pitches 62 strikes two walks
five strikeouts crichton ready in the
bullpen
and that's going to be it for merrell
kelly stefan creighton comes in
tied at three in the seventh muncie's
walk spells the end of the game for miro
kelly turner turns on it sends it in the
air down the line towards the pole
it is gone two-run home run for turner
greeting the bullpen rudely and breaking
the tie in the seventh
albert pujols goes to the plate base is
loaded one gone
that is pulled through the left side
base here albert pujols delivers again
station to station on an rbi single that
makes it
6-3 on 1-2
mckinney grounds one over the mound it
ramps to shore
ahmed stumbles and gets to the bag just
in time
but pollock is in to score and they lead
7-3 who hosts one for one
pin [ __ ] rbi shingle muscles this one
into left field for another one batted
in
on his career total two for two with a
pair of rbis tonight
and the d-backs down to their last out
another payoff
got him and a one two three nine for
edwin usada to finish this one off
bullpen game for the dodgers they win at
8-3 and will go for the series win
tomorrow